[Music]
it's foundations
[Music]
forget about
wrong
[Music]
a term I really like to describe at the
field that I'm an in the areas that I
research is creative computing the name
of this old computer magazine at a time
when the home computer allowed a lot of
people to experiment and find out what
the computer could do in terms of
creating Beauty joy entertainment
I'm a writer and a poet
interactive fiction and story generators
I'm very interested in language and
specifically what the computer can do in
these sorts of modes with language one
thing you can do with computers is to
create really giant systems that embody
certain ideas about cognition narrative
and they're a very large-scale
multi-year projects that use the
computer as a way to investigate how
stories are put together for instance so
I have a project curve ship that is such
a system this is a project that builds
on their to theory it also builds on you
know existing very good models for how
to put interactive fiction together and
tries to take the form of interactive
fiction in a new dimension there's a lot
of experimentalism in it there's a lot
of constrained writing in it there's a
lot of use of language and metaphor and
specific ways in it there's
experimentation with narrative and loops
and it's a very easy field because it
brings a lot of people who have
interests in high theory but also in how
these theories get applied into actual
production of avant-garde art I also
like to sketch and create very
small-scale story generators poetry
generators you know other systems that I
might think about for a while and then
execute in a few hours
Taroko Gorge which I wrote in one day
in Taiwan it has these single lines that
are very long and that you can't see the
end of that trail off which are like the
tunnels and
taroko gorge and then these longer runs
up lines which describe things that you
might see on cats outside and so it's
meant to simulate in a certain way the
process of walking through this park
some of my friends and fellow writers
and colleagues have taken this up and
made their own versions like scott
refworks tokyo garage which is based on
the code that i wrote but uses a large
body of text that he brought in to
replace what I had written instead of
being a portrait of a place that he
visited it's his imagination of what
Tokyo is like based on all sorts of
cultural stereotypes that we have in the
West and then jr. carpenter developed
the piece about the excesses of
consumption and eating that was simply
called gorge so even though this is a
simple piece that I did in one day it
offered to some other people a way in to
think about how language might combine
and how they might produce not just a
single text but a generator of language
that gave us an interesting texture
[Music]
I like this type of capability the
ability to sketch with visual media and
work with this and and to actually try
out ideas by thinking through them in
code and seeing how they work the same
way that I might write something in my
notebook between the lab model of the
sciences where there's a lab director
and then students do work and the
solitaire model of the humanities
there's not much possibility really for
for the sort of collaboration in the
world right now but I'm trying to open
up those particular sorts of
possibilities and find ways that aren't
hierarchical on the one hand or
completely isolated on the other of
doing academic work
[Music]
you
you